i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle from san francisco tonight
now you don't have to go all the way to
afghanistan to see widespread suffering
and despair or to witness a tragic
breakdown in civil society
you can see that right here just miles
from multi-million dollar homes owned by
the billionaire titans of the tech world
now homelessness and drug abuse it's
been a problem here for decades but the
situation now is spiraling totally out
of control earlier today just a block
from a major police precinct
we saw people doing crack on the street
and washing their clothes at a dirty
leaky hydrant
this once great american city is
cratering
and while we're horrified rightly so as
the taliban terrorizes the people of
afghanistan
why are so many num when our people are
being terrorized here
it's a democrat engineered american
tragedy
but are the voters finally rising up
what we're going to show you tonight
will shock you
but first
the great unraveling that's the focus of
tonight's angle
the humiliation of america is unfolding
before our eyes in a dramatic fashion
our president is incapable or unwilling
to do the basic tasks of his job from
enforcing our border at home to
protecting our national security abroad
his policies have made america more
dangerous
the basic cost of living is more
expensive today our people are more
divided we see that everywhere
he staffed his administration with an
assortment of radicals and incompetence
from his homeland security secretary to
his defense secretary we see nothing but
examples of ineptitude and arrogance
now the taliban is laughing at us
the corruption that plagues the pentagon
and state department
is staggering
here's just a few of the low lights
first the pentagon which has a budget
remember of over 700 billion dollars
somehow didn't realize that the afghan
army had spent billions training would
collapse in just 11 days
neither our secretary of defense nor the
chairman of the joint chiefs could
explain why they were so unprepared
both should have been fired i said this
they should have been fired last week
and determined to double down on failure
biden's people want you to believe that
the taliban can be trusted with american
safety
it's absolutely re requiring of us
to keep these lines of communication
with the taliban open who do have
checkpoints out beyond the airport um
and uh what we have seen is that this
coordination has well this deconfliction
has worked well um in terms of uh
allowing access and flow to continue
what a buffoon second despite spending
two decades trying to build a
functioning afghan government
the state department was somehow totally
shocked when afghan president ashraf
ghani fled the country leaving us
holding the bag well not that secretary
of state tony blinken even remembers who
that is
go back a week
the government fell
and by the way i was on the phone with
with president karzai the day before
when he was telling me his intent is he
put it to fight to the death well the
next day he was gone
news flash tony karzai hasn't been the
afghan president since 2014.
yes ladies and gentlemen
that is our chief diplomat
all right third our intelligence
community which is supposed to be the
most able and sophisticated in the world
also failed to see any of this coming
by this team could have gotten better
advice from watching this show than
listening to the same people who spent
more time on the narrative of january 6
than our exit from afghanistan
now fourth
the two elected officials in the white
house biden and harris
apparently have little to no role at all
in policy making
harris is so unimportant that the biden
folks just sent her on a trip to
southeast asia
now this suggests that biden's aides
think harris is not only useless during
a crisis but a liability
frankly i think that's the best decision
they've made over the past week send her
out
and poor old joe of course he can't
answer basic questions about extracting
americans from harm's way
what i'm not going to do is talk about
the tactical changes we're making i
don't want to go into the detailed power
doing that again i don't want to get
into detail about it
because he doesn't know the details
finally under biden our credibility and
our prestige is shot mr foreign policy
the dems and the gop warhawks they spent
a lot of time remember trying to
convince the voters that donald trump
hurt america's reputation around the
world
that was a lie
our enemies feared president trump and
our allies grudgingly respected him even
if they didn't like him all the time
they knew his priority was america first
but with biden and his cabinet
they know it's america on our heels
i mean does anyone now trust secretary
blinken to negotiate with the chinese of
the russians of course not
does anyone trust secretary austin and
general military successfully organize a
military operation that's more complex
than let's say the army navy football
game
no
now let's be clear
every major player on earth knows that
the u.s national security is in the
hands of incompetent blunderers
they all know that as long as this team
remains in place china will gain power
at our expense
but here's the bitter truth
no one close to joe biden really cares
chuck schumer doesn't care
nancy pelosi is hannity said is holding
fundraisers and nap on mask lists she's
so worried about cobit
no democrats in the center of the house
care at all
no one in the democratic party is
calling for firings or resignations or
even demanding accountability
the fact is they would rather keep
proven incompetence in office with all
the problems that creates for our
national security
then risk losing a single vote in 2024
the pattern of repeated failures though
without zero accountability
is happening here in california just the
same
now we know everyone knows that governor
gavin newsom has done a horrific job
here
the unemployment rate in california is
7.6 percent
cnbc is ranking california 47th and the
cost of doing business here 50th dead
last in business friendliness
crime skyrocketing
and here in san francisco the situation
as i said is rapidly deteriorating
the stats i've been seeing is that
homicides burglaries car break-ins
way-ups they're all back on the rise
since 2019 correct especially violent
crimes um robberies i'm sorry homicides
are up 85
85 percent yeah i think i got it at 30
i'd say no they're way up there our
non-fatal shootings are up
democrat policies here have emboldened
criminals
murders shootings carjackings all going
through the roof now more of my
reporting on this later on in the show
and again democrats who could do
something about it
just don't care
when millions of californians desperate
for some relief from these crises turned
to this effort to recall governor gavin
newsom the democratic party they didn't
even put forward an alternative
candidate to replace newsome instead
they simply urged californians to reject
the recall and accept further decline
now compare all of this everything
what's been happening on the gop side of
politics
because we also had an elite
that also failed we also had leaders who
were unable or unwilling to defend our
interests
and one by one
we push them out
the bushes and the cheneys are gone
replaced by leaders who are much more
closely aligned with what the voters
want because in this country we don't
have to accept failed leaders we have
the power to replace them and that's
what we should do
so biden may not care if the u.s goes
down the drain but we voters
we can replace his democratic allies in
2022 and replace him in 2024.
so newsome obviously doesn't care about
the problems here in california but the
voters here will have their say on
september 14th
and if they vote to recall him
they can begin to take their state back
remember they want you to feel helpless
they want you to believe that they're
doing the best they can and if and that
it can't be any better than it is right
now that's just not true the greatest
politician in california's history put
it this way
i will not stand by and watch this great
country
destroy itself under mediocre leadership
that drifts when run crisis to the next
eroding our national will and purpose
we have come together here because the
american people deserve better
from those to whom they entrust our
nation's highest officers
and we stand united
we stand united in our resolve to do
something about it
what was true in the carter era is true
in the biden era californians deserve
better
americans deserve better
everything biden and newsome touch is
unraveling
including their poll numbers
but we don't have to allow this
embarrassing spectacle to continue
indefinitely if we do
the cruel jokes on us
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else